alors déjà lors du débat du premier tour
donc avant le premier tour le dimanche 8
mars était le thème central c'est l
hôpital qui avait été le premier thème
abordé avec les dix petits d'amy je
pense que sa survie est toujours
d'actualité
on va faire un premier tour de table sur
cette question commençant par vous
monsieur millet vous comment vous avez
géré cette épidémie covit 19 dans votre
ville est ce que c'était le maire qui
agissaient où il était le candidat pour
le 2e tour aux états le maire évidemment
parce que c'est le travail du maire de
s'occuper de sa population et d'en
prendre soin nous avons appelé les
personnes les plus âgées enfin depuis 70
ans
c'est pas très âgée mais une fois par
semaine ça fait quand même 800 appels
par semaine nous avons commandé des
masses nous avons quand même investi
cent mille cent mille euros pour pour
pour tous l'approvisionnement en
matériel angers leurs masques etc
donc il ya eu un effort de fait est
énorme par rapport aux habitants dont il
faut se procurer passe ya beaucoup de
personnes isolées qui n'ont occupé par
des préoccupé parce que vous allez vous
procurer non nous préoccuper les
préoccupent je vais te permets tu
voudras aucune personne qui sont isolées
et il fallait absolument prendre de
leurs nouvelles si elle peut avoir
besoin de courses de de choses diverses
de repas domicile voilà mais ça c'était
le travail du maire nuneta pas dans le
registre médical chacun son métier
francis lahaut la gestion des épidémies
par jean-louis millet maire sortant et
candidat vous avez regardé ça comment
mais moi ce que je regarde surtout c'est
comment l'hôpital s'est comportée et
comment il a répondu en ayant été
complètement désossé à saint-claude
comme ailleurs démunis fragilisé comment
il a il a pu répondre avec des
personnels admirable mais avec 63 agents
en moins que ce que nous avions avant la
fermeture de nos trois services
et alors en fermant la chirurgie
complète aussi qu'avant nous perdu nous
avons perdu une équipe de 15 infirmières
infirmiers vous pensez que saurait cette
donne deux anesthésistes
je vous en prie catherine ce 103
personnes en plus ça aurait changé la
face des choses sans rien changer
beaucoup de choses ça aurait permis
qu'ils soient redéployés pour une grande
partie sur l'ensemble de
l'établissement est ce la raque permis
au personnel qui restait d'être aidés et
de ne pas avoir été il l'aurait été mais
aussi épuisé à bout qui l'ont été et
puis autre chose
la chirurgie complète qu'est-ce que cela
permettait et bien cela permettait de la
réanimation car il y avait une équipe de
15 infirmières infirmiers sous
l'autorité de deux anesthésistes qui
étaient là en permanence servi
respirateur catherine excusez-moi 18
respirateur dans notre petit hôpital qui
nous ont fait défaut et c'est préfet du
jura qui a dit heureusement qu'il y
avait dijon et besançon cas nous
n'aurions pas pu répondre à lons avec
les respirateurs et les personnels que
nous avions si nous avions eu cela à
saint claude
nous aurions pu répondre a fini mon
mieux
frédéric pons est je vous voyais déjà
réagir en hochant la tête vous n'êtes
pas vraiment d'accord elle exclut
viennent dire francis lahaut n'ont pas
vraiment d'abord je voulais dire
qu'effectivement monsieur jean
l'humilier maire sortant a été dans son
rôle effectivement de mer chacun dans
ses rôles et fonctions moi je suis à la
région aujourd'hui et donc nous avons
travaillé avec la présidente et
l'exécutif régional à accompagner au
mieux la situation économique a financé
le stage des infirmières etc pour
qu'effectivement la région puissent
aussi sur un territoire comme
saint-claude être présente
non je ne partage pas ce qu'il vient de
dire je le ferai francis lahaut pardon
parce que je crois que nous nous avons
eu des soignants au sein de l'hôpital et
des médecins qui ont fait extrêmement
bien leur travail et les 65
ça manquait pas seulement cinq personnes
ont dû être transférés à lons le saunier
pour une observation un petit peu plus
poussé voilà le résultat il est là je
crois qu'encore une fois nous nous
sommes un établissement de proximité ne
sommes pas un chu donc vous pensez que
le l'hôpital de saint-claude tels qu'ils
les structures est aujourd'hui ça
suffisait largement pour gérer cette
histoire de covin de 10
moi je crois surtout que cet hôpital il
doit et les élus et les usagers doivent
regarder devant eux
voilà pour reconstruire cette offre de
soins qui nous est indispensable et
surtout et le seul enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est la capacité de cet établissement à
recruter des médecins on développera
tout à l'ats jean-louis millet votre
réaction aux propos qui viennent d'être
j'ai partagé tout à fait les propos de
francis lahaut par contre l'hôpital n'a
pas tenu on a eu quelques personnes
transférées à lens où on n'a eu qu'à me
8 décès huit décès duo kobe d' décédé à
l'hôpital et ses mots qui enregistrent
les décès en mairie de saint claude ils
sont officiellement déclarés avec des
certificats médicaux qui a dicté qui a
dit que la cause du décès je suis désolé
monsieur pons s'est alors lui avoue dit
il n'avait jamais été informée de la
situation pourquoi vous dites que les
tâches des remords mais vous allez avoir
été informée par mes services qui
enregistre l idée on vous étiez très
bien informé vous étiez très très bien
l'hôpital j'ai des réformes et des 8-17
parlent nos services vous ont des sujets
précis juste que les relations entre le
maire de saint cloud
l hôpital sont difficiles voire rompu
inexistante inexistante puisque le sud
je suis je suis devenu l'ennemi du
directeur alors que le directeur
d'oyonnax le maire d'oyonnax
s'entretenait tous les matins à 9 heures
ainsi qu'à dole je n'ai jamais eu une
seule alors à canon sciatique du
directeur nous sur les respirateurs dont
monsieur là haut a fait allusion et sur
le rôle de la région s'il vous plaît
dans le rôle de la région la région est
intervenue avec nés entre autres des
commandes de masques pour tous publics
qui sont arrivés après la bataille et
qui ne sont pas un cadeau puisque ont eu
leurs factures j'ai sur mon bureau une
facture de 19000 euros à payer à la
communauté de communes qui va les
reverser à la région je parle des
masques tout public
on est bien d'accord du match là-bas
vers utilisent moi je voudrais attirer
l'attention
le convient de 7,8 chose c'est une crise
il y avait quand même eu à la résidence
du mont-gaillard maison de retraite au
niveau 3 sur 29 lits 24 contamination et
on a le record de contamination du
personnel avec 22 personnes contaminées
parmi le personnel sur 40 dans tunz est
et jura sud
oui surtout surtout l'ensemble des
structures hôpital et autres jeux
rassuré sur la maison de retraite la
diff ont donc le personnes contaminées
jura sud ses 2600 salariés
un klaus et 10% et les 10% de salariés
des personnels représentent 50% des
contaminations vendredi que certains
n'ont pas bien fait leur boulot
le boulot ces connards responsable
service coville a baladé le service la
déménager trois fois transporté le virus
dans tout l'établissement et en est le
résultat inévitable qu'on a pu constater
je voulais juste vous faire réagir fait
des réponses et sur le rôle de la région
donc ce ne sont pas des dons c'est
simplement la région qui s'est organisée
pour commander massivement des masques
et après les faire payer par les
collectivités saint claudais d'autres il
ya eu deux choses il ya eu des commandes
de masques qui ont été offertes au
personnel soignant
comment au personnel dans les camps tout
dans les ehpad et c'est à ceux là ont
été offerts gratuitement
voilà on a joué cette solidarité là les
vidéos faire payant ensuite la région a
tout de suite compris que quand les
quelques distributeurs les quelques
fabricants étaient écrouées soûles et
sous les commandes et une commande de 4
millions de masques par rapport à une
petite commune qui commandent 200
masques
je veux dire voilà et ce qui était
important c'est que ces petites communes
elles puissent être aussi bien servi et
un prix aussi bien attractifs que ceux
qui sont en capacité de faire de très
grandes commandes
vous avez comment vous avez fait une
première commande de masques monsieur le
maire et vous êtes porté à l'anam écueil
que nous c'est à dire que votre commande
elle n'a pas suivi et vous être abattus
effectivement sur ceux de la région et
c'est bon c'est vous êtes au coeur bat y
avait commandé des masques en chine j'en
ai pour 15000 euros jeudi reçu trois
semaines avant la région ce qui a permis
de faire une distribution avant tout le
monde
15 millions d'euros gelés livrés en
suisse pour pas combien de 15,15
millions de noms du cac à 2000 euros par
dont 15 millions c'est un peu excessif
de l'âme en campagne électorale c'est un
peu beaucoup dans nos possibilités
quinze mille euros aux vins à faire or à
faire en chine et nous les avons eu
trois semaines d'avoir la région parce
que nous sommes bougeait bien avant la
région nous avons été servis en temps et
en heure
francis lahaut est le plus fort sur ce
il ya d'être dit si nous avions eu nos
trois soeurs riesch je crois que j'ai
expliqué frédéric piquionne n'a pas
répondu
nous aurions été moins démuni pour
répondre à cette pandémie est ce qu'il
faudrait que nous disent frédéric pons
et car il entretient l'incertitude sur
cette question c'est qu'il est contre la
réouverture de la maternité et de la
pédiatrie et de la chirurgie complète il
faudra qu'ils l'avouent à tous ses
électeurs il en voudra le dire
clairement
frédéric et cesser de répondre à côté
alors que les choses soient claires je
ne renonce zelaya pour ça oui je ne
renonce absolument pas moi et mes
colistiers à ce qu'il y ait un jour de
nouveau des naissances à saint claude
voilà simplement je suis conscient de ce
qui a fait que cette maternité a fermé
j'habite saint claud depuis 25 ans
depuis 25 ans j'entends que cette
maternité et sous l'écueil de pouvoir
fermer
voilà qu'est ce qu'on a fait pendant 25
ans cette maternité elle a fermé parce
qu'on n'a pas su garder le nombre de
naissances suffisant pour qu'elle
fonctionne bien et deuxièmement parce
qu'on a pas su garder les médecins voilà
la maternité avant tout c'est une
question de sécurité sécurité dans les
accouchements
vous vous prenez effectivement une
maternité au rabais moi je suis
interpellé
pratiquement tous les jours par des
femmes et des hommes qui ont perdu un
enfant et qui me disent une maternité
oui mais pas n'importe et a dû à
saint-claude une maternité à bord de la
route avec et sa bouche mans sur la
borne lancé faut assumer c'est une
maternité terni une métairie mépris une
maternité de niveau 3 que vous défendez
dans un avenir aux calendes grecques qui
ne viendra jamais aujourd'hui nous avons
une maternité nous avions et nous aurons
demain de niveau 1 et qui permet de
répondre à 80 % des accouchements qui se
font dans des conditions normales et
lorsqu'il ya un problème
la parturiente et transféré c'est
infiniment mieux que d'accoucher sur le
bord de la route
le septième accouchement sur le bord de
la route le 15 mai lecture qui est
effectué hier par monsieur millet de ses
patients de cette part turrian tu qui
demande que l'on
ouvre la maternité je vous ai dit demain
l'avenir l'avenir qu'est ce que c'est au
dernier conseil de surveillance le
directeur nous a dit la stérilisation
il faut l'externaliser car cela a un
coût la part monsieur la stérilisation
stérilisation la stérilisation de tout
ce dont nous avons besoin pour faire des
opérations je ne suis pas chirurgien
dans de bonnes conditions sanitaires
externaliser la pharmacie externalisés à
lens
mais le laboratoire et je termine mon
cher frédéric et le laboratoire
il faut l'externaliser car cela a un
coût il faut le déporter même le mot est
admirable à 5 l'autre il faut le déporté
mais le déporter quand nous avons des
urgences 24 heures sur 24 que nous avons
gagné maintenu grâce à notre
mobilisation sans quoi elles étaient
condamnées et bien comment fait-on
travail et des urgences 24 heures sur 24
quand nous n'avons pas de laboratoire
expliquez-nous cela monsieur du côlon on
ne la voit et on a des micros c'est bon
vous n'êtes pas obligé de crier tout
vent joie je la réponse monsieur pons et
moi un piano va passer à autre chose à
faire quand je vous entends je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on a perdu des
services dans cette dans cet hôpital
alors que vous êtes ou ou responsabilité
depuis 25 ans un quart de siècle dans
cet hôpital quand vous dites vous c est
monsieur laobé mmos y avait rien faire
le plateau technique il ya 25 ans avec
l'avangard il écoute avec le comité
défense que j'ai créées dont j'étais à
l'origine et tu n'as rien fait mon oui
je sais je te sourit parce que tu n'as
pas de répondre non mais si ma réponse
suite des années
je suis désolé rien fait pendant 25 ans
es tu ne feras il ya demain francis je
suis désolé je n'ai pas ton âge